[Música]
este domingo 21 de noviembre poco más de
15 millones de chilenos están llamados a
las urnas los ciudadanos llegan a estos
comicios completamente divididos en un
escenario político completamente
polarizado ante esto todos los
escenarios son posibles y la segunda
vuelta es un hecho por la falta de
claridad sobre quién será el sucesor del
actual presidente sebastián piñera los
candidatos presidenciales que aspiran a
gobernar chile desde marzo de 2022 han
repetido que las elecciones donde se
eligen también a los parlamentarios son
las más importantes de los últimos 30
años e incluso de las décadas que vienen
las votaciones están enmarcadas en un
contexto particular no sólo porque el
gobierno que se va se va debilitado sino
también por la convención constitucional
las huellas de un estallido social de
octubre 2019 que dio paso a esta nueva
constitución y sobre todo una
fragmentación política que hará más
compleja esta formación de coaliciones
tras la previsible segunda vuelta que
tendrá lugar en el mes de diciembre por
ello quiero saludar en este momento
entonces a marta lago es ella esa funda
de latinobarómetro y mori y chile
gracias marta por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 le pregunto
por qué son llamadas inciertas y las más
colar izadas estas elecciones siete
candidatos y ninguno convence qué pasa
en chile
bueno muy buenos días mire la verdad es
que aquí estamos en la parte más baja de
la crisis política más importante que ha
tenido chile en un siglo
esta crisis política se produce por
múltiples razones pero se acentúa
enormemente en este gobierno y
especialmente después de
el estallido social que se produce en el
año 19 entonces estas elecciones
presidenciales son un indicador de la
crisis es decir la incertidumbre de los
candidatos del hecho que tengamos un
candidato de extrema derecha que hoy día
tiene posibilidad de llegar al palacio
de la moneda es todo una expresión de la
misma crisis de representación que en el
fondo viene del rayado de la cancha que
dejó el dictador augusto pinochet con su
constitución del 80 que es la
constitución que estamos tratando de
cambiar ahora marta lo que usted decía
pues se llama la atención porque
pareciera que gabriel boric pudiera ser
no uno de los favoritos teniendo en
cuenta que el gobierno actual del
presidente sebastián piñera actualmente
de derecha está muy por debajo con todos
los escándalos también con lo que salió
en los pandora papers pues ya sabemos
que el senado tumbó este proceso de
destitución del presidente pero usted
está diciendo que entonces josé antonio
kast del frente social cristiano es el
como el más favorito él podría ganar
como está a esta competición entre estos
dos candidatos los más sonados
bueno después del debate del lunes
yo creo que quedó claro que el domingo
va a salir primero es decir va a sacar
la mayor cantidad de votos gabriel boric
que es el candidato de la izquierda de
la oposición y va a salir en segundo
lugar el candidato josé antonio kast
este candidato hacia un mes un mes y
medio no tenía ninguna opción de llegar
a la presidencia y se convirtió en uno
que tenía opción porque el candidato que
era de centroderecha cometió muchos
errores y perdió mucho apoyo entonces
estamos en esta situación blanco negro
no siento que es donde el candidato de
extrema derecha dice yo o el caos era la
misma opción que tenían los chilenos en
octubre del 88 cuando votamos en contra
del dictador entonces hay una sensación
muy extraña porque el gobierno hace un
pésimo gobierno fue probablemente el
peor gobierno de la historia chile no
tiene ningún apoyo de la población y sin
embargo surge este candidato autoritario
que defiende a pinochet que dice que
pinochet votaría por él si estuviera
vivo
y que de repente tiene una cantidad de
apoyo entonces aquí hay una por eso digo
estamos en la parte más profunda de una
crisis donde la mitad de la gente no
vota a 1 de cada 2 chilenos desde el año
2012 no vota y donde la probabilidad de
que mañana vote la gente que suele votar
que más o menos también la otra mitad yo
creo que es baja yo creo que mañana el
domingo va a votar menos gente que la
usual
también simbolizando de nuevo la
profundidad de la crisis entonces son
muchas las
excepcionalidades que se dan en esta
elección donde surge esta extrema
derecha bueno en francia- estar
acostumbrado a la extrema derecha hace
rato acá creímos que la habíamos de
alguna manera ha dejado de lado no pero
surge con una fuerza inesperada a último
minuto en la elección ahora no hay
ninguna opción de los otros candidatos
hablo de sebastián así que les yasna
provoste o franco parisi ellos no
podrían pasar de ninguna manera la
segunda vuelta digamos que es un
escenario tan incierto como estamos
hablando pues todo puede pasar no pero
usted pues como como analista político
como chilena también que vive la
realidad de su país que puede pasar con
ellos tres al olvido
bueno en el caso es sebastián si se le
está la gran interrogante porque
nosotros tenemos 15 días de veda de
encuestas por lo tanto no hemos sabido
cuál es la que como se ha podido medir
después del debate del 2 del lunes que
sucedió con el electorado porque el
lunes josé antonio kast digamos se
despeñó muy mal y sí que se desempeñó
muy bien y claramente perdió votos a
favor de sitges
no no yo no descartaría aunque lo
encuentro poco probable la posibilidad
de que sí se logre pasar a casa es decir
a partir del lunes eso se vuelve una
posibilidad es decir no muy probable
pero sí no imposible
lo que le muestra que en realidad aquí
el problema está en la derecha a la
derecha como tiene un gobierno tan malo
no tiene una propuesta de futuro
sólida y por lo tanto los los votantes
de derecha van para un lado van para el
otro lado andan un poco desesperadamente
buscando no ser toda la mejor opción
para parar a la izquierda en este
momento el mensaje de la derecha es
paremos a la izquierda marc los oí
también se conoce muchas gracias no
siento estas elecciones que son todos en
contra de la segunda vuelta va a ser
sobre eso va a ser sobre paremos en las
que la oposición se va a decir paremos a
la extrema derecha y el extrema derecha
se va a decir para la izquierda marta
tengo un minuto antes de terminar esta
conversación que por cierto está muy
interesante pero no quiero despedirla
sin hablar tres retos puntuales que le
esperan el próximo presidente chileno
bueno un parlamento atomizado con una
gran dificultad de formar coalición para
poder gobernar que después está el tema
de la economía que estamos con una
altísima inflación
los salarios que están en un estado
sumamente bajos y por lo tanto también
un gran descontento de la población que
sin duda va a estar en las calles en el
momento que se acabe la pandemia
definitivamente quienquiera que sea el
gobierno que viene en los chilenos van a
estar protestando para tener un futuro
mejor entonces el próximo gobierno hace
un gobierno extremadamente difícil una
con una gobernabilidad compleja
que va a tener que enfrentar todos los
problemas de la pandemia pero también
los problemas del estallido social